quando eu era pequeno e eu aprendi a
andar de bicicleta aos 12 anos graças ao
meu pai porque senão ela teria pedido
que ele convenceu a minha mãe de que dá
certo que ia ser seguro então ele me
incentivou a economia está existindo
aqui o que é importante
nem que fosse necessário
graças à minha mãe eu me tornaria
conhecido que foi que ela me cuidou
então mesmo que eu sabia que podia
contar com ela para cuidar de mim pra
quando voltasse atrás e hoje eu carrego
dentro de mim essas duas forças
meu pai e minha mãe
a força do feminino e do masculino
é justamente isso que me faz andar na
vida que é a força que me faz ter desejo
de i a aventura inesperado e ao mesmo
tempo saber que existe a preocupação com
cuidado a preocupação com o carinho do
masculino ela é uma energia poderosa
disposição uma energia de criação dia de
coragem e força e é importante que a
gente iniciar as coisas
as coisas acontecerem é impulso que joga
lá pra frente e acredito feminino ela se
faz de consciência sobre o movimento
ela te faça consciência sobre o que
impacto daquela situação
ela esteve no cuidado e na energia que
tem olhar se filie sobre a vida é
energia que sabe no trio então é a
pergunta que eu faço é porque nós
enfrentemos nós criamos projetos sem
integrar essas duas forças dentro de nós
nós fizemos isso durante muitos e muitos
anos a revolução industrial que foi uma
energia de expansão tão importante para
que a gente chegasse de gestão hoje a
nível de construção a nível de evolução
a todas a questão do consumo toda
certeza o capitalismo a gente estude
muito com a energia
nessa época nessa área industrial e isso
foi um grande movimento de energia
masculina foi um grande movimento que
foi importante para a criação das
cidades de toda a civilização que a
gente tem hoje
só que enquanto não dizemos isso
desconectado da energia feminina
o que a gente começa a perceber é uma
evolução absurda mas a gente fica um
a ponto de colocar em nome dessa
evolução dessa produção despedida
a gente que é o ponto de colocar veneno
na nossa própria comida para produzir
mais
a gente fica um pouco de simplesmente
começa a criar remédios por causa desse
veneno que a gente coloca nossa comida
ea energia do cuidar energia feminina
ficou completamente esquecida durante
esse período de evolução mas como ele
define uma região muito forte
ela não pode ficar simplesmente olhando
pra isso tudo era preciso fazê lo de
forma também separada da energia
ferramenta linhas de masculina e criou o
que a gente chama hoje de
assistencialismo que um monte de pessoas
bem vindo moderadas que não acreditam
que são capazes de dar conta da própria
vida que não acreditam que são capazes
de se manter sem a existência de alguma
instituição
eu cuidado mas vou convidar o luís e
nunca que não pudera que não traz a
força da energia masculina
então a gente precisou criar ong está
cuidado as baleias porque a indústria
como os maiores a gente crie precisou
criar instituições para cuidar do câncer
porque a gente está concluindo os
alimentos estavam ciganos nós então onde
realmente isso vai parar
se a gente não se conscientizaram da
importância de integrar a elite feminino
e esse masculino
então nós criamos um evento na verdade
de barulhos e quarta dias pessoas
integradas que não sabe como evoluir
dessa decepção que eu observo são hoje
os grandes
os dois jovens porque não deve ter
passado só com estudos que lhe uma banda
né e hoje eles querem ter o quê mas a
tap
acho que os jovens são uma coisa em
garagens é negócio de banco é porque a
gente vê todo mundo querendo aprender
só que 99,9 por cento dos estados a caça
ea gente está seguindo todo mundo mesmo
modelo são os mesmos formados as mesmas
ferramentas aos mesmos livros que a
gente tá lendo a gente vem seguindo
esses modelos mas é um modelo de
inclusão onde poucos escolhidos vão
cercava o campeão
e esse cavalo campeão está a serviço de
quem
quem é que realmente for questra uma
fábrica de seres humanos inteligentes
que trabalham sem ou mais por semana
talvez recebem renda
a pergunta que eu faço até onde nós
vamos pegar com esse movimento se a
gente não ia ficar tá o essencial
se a gente não resgatar aquilo que
realmente constitui esse nosso poder de
andar na vida íntegros tendo percepção
de impacto nos anos do evento
então eu fico imaginando a energia
feminina ea masculina se reencontrando
no alto daquela pedra lá quem sabe
olhando pra baixo pensando assim puxa
que saudade dos tempos que os povos
quando matava um animal
agradeci uma vida tadão para matar a
fome
que saudade do tempo onde a gente
respeitava o tempo da terra
o ciclo da vida de um trilho e de colher
a gente não tenha tanto os desertos
talvez hoje esse movimento
então o que fazer
o que fazer a mudança ela vai vir das
pessoas que estão lá
precisando de um prato de comida mas ela
também não vai vir das pessoas que estão
porque estrango per capita lisa a
mudança da vida de pessoas como nós que
acreditam que é possível
fui na vida com a mudança foi na vida de
forma íntegra
então a partir disso começa a nascer um
novo olhar um olhar do empreendedorismo
[Música]
de transformar tudo em pequenas
caixinhas e querer fazer um olhar apenas
de uma qualidade mas quando a gente
integra tudo isso quando a gente
simplesmente vai empreender primeiro
conectado com a nossa essência
olhando para aquilo que a gente tem de
uma hora e integrando os poderes
femininos e masculinos dos nossos pais
das nossas mães que nos ensinavam para a
vida se não cuidar ele ser humano hilux
começa a olhar ele se olhar o mundo ele
é fluido porque empoderado é forte e daí
a gente começa não mais existe a
necessidade de seguir os modelos
nos colocou que na verdade só tá tocando
de modelos
a gente não consegue criar modelos
próprios porque a gente termina sempre
uma caixinha para entrar na outra
então quando a gente fala de emprego
desde sempre não ficamos falando disso
nós estamos falando de empresas mais
orgânicas
estamos falando de poder os negócios
mais interdependentes interconectados
onde a gente consegue criar uma nova
comunidade onde a gente consegue copiar
os negócios e muitas vezes as pessoas
acham que isso é romantismo mas não é a
forma mais abundante porque ela não é
exclusiva ela não é para poucos
hoje nós sabemos que o problema da fome
no mundo ele só existe justamente porque
é a cadeia produtiva se existe um número
absurdo sem foods brasil tentado sobre
isso ea gente sabe que o problema só
poderá ser resolvido que seja empresa
todos na cadeia de forma sistêmica
então realmente programa web falta não é
que não tenha todo mundo é que não tenha
todo mundo é interessante porque gera
escassez ea escassez gera competição ea
competição alimento em khar turismo
então a gente precisa acreditar que é
abundante e como é que a gente acredita
que é importante que a gente vai levar
na mala desse novo empreendedorismo
quais são as ferramentas onde a gente
vai se inspirar
se a gente não se expõe o modelo se a
gente não se inspira em livros agentes
a organização mais inteligente do
planeta que é a natureza
você já viu uma floresta organizada a
gente fazer aqui galera na sequência só
nessa região borboletinhas abelhas galé
o seguinte mas não vai colocar na outra
seja mesmo por esta é interdependente
ninguém menos importante o mais
importante do ecossistema
então a gente tem muito para aprender
com a natureza a gente sabe médica e 300
de alta tecnologia sendo desenvolvida
espelhadas justamente na natureza tem
instalados foram criados pirata
iniciadas
esperamos um furão que tem capacidade
para travar e fazer faculdade e não ter
prejuízo está ou não na natureza tudo
porque a gente vai buscar referências em
livros se a gente pode simplesmente
olhar as árvores e quando a gente faz
isso a gente traz um olhar um simples
uma referência muito simples a gente
começar a dar neste momento
primeiro de tudo é eu comigo quem eu sou
como estou de boca depois a minha
relação eu com o outro e quando eu olho
o outro me preocupa relação eu olho eu
você ea gente copia uma nova história
uma nova comunidade mas integrando mais
interdependente mais conectada
[Aplausos]